안녕하세요, 제 이름은 Olivia Lan이고 IBM Quantum의 연구원이자 교육자예요. 이 영상은
Qiskit YouTube 채널과 저희 학습 플랫폼에서 새롭게 시작하는 시리즈의 출발점이에요. 시리즈 이름은 '실전 Quantum Computing'이에요.
간단히 말하면, 이 시리즈에서는 지금 실제로 존재하는 양자 컴퓨터를 최대한 활용하는 방법을 알려드릴 거예요.
인터넷에는 이미 양자 컴퓨터와 미래 가능성, 또는 양자 계산의 이론적 개념에 관한 영상이 수십억 개나 있어요.
물론 그런 내용도 똑같이 중요해요. 예를 들어 John Watrous가 진행하는 '양자 정보와 계산 이해하기'도 있죠.
하지만 이 강좌에서는 수강생이 이전보다 조금 더 많은 배경 지식을 가지고 있다고 가정하고,
기술적으로 굉장히 깊이 들어갈 거예요. 지난 한 해 동안,
그리고 이 영상을 녹화하는 2024년 현재, 우리는 새로운 계산의 시대로 넘어가는 전환점을 목격하고 있어요.
양자 컴퓨터가 드디어 실제로 유용해질 수 있는 지점에 다가오고 있어요. 소규모 circuit과 양자 컴퓨터로 실험하는 것이
커뮤니티에 이 기계를 활용하는 방법을 교육하는 데 필요했지만, 당시에는 일반 고전 컴퓨터로도 할 수 있는 실험만 하고 있었어요.
하지만 오늘날 우리는 양자 유용성의 시대에 들어섰어요.
그럼 유용성이란 무엇일까요? 이건 양자 우위와는 달라요. 양자 우위는
양자 컴퓨터가 의미 있는 과제에서 고전 컴퓨터를 능가하는 시점을 말해요. 반면 유용성이란
서로 경쟁할 수 있게 되는 것을 의미하고, 이것이 기술 발전의 자연스러운 다음 단계예요.
IBM이 작년에 발표한 논문에서 처음으로 양자 컴퓨터가 물리 모델을 시뮬레이션하고
최첨단 고전 시뮬레이션 기법과 경쟁할 수 있다는 걸 보여줬어요. 심지어
브루트 포스 방식보다도 나은 결과를 내서, 연구자들에게 새로운 연구 방향을 열어줬어요. 왜 이게 지금
일어나고 있냐고요? 지난 몇 달 사이 IBM이 100 qubit 이상의 양자 프로세서를 널리 공개했거든요.
이미 사용자라면, 더 큰 칩을 위한 공간을 만들기 위해 소형 프로세서를 많이 내린 걸 눈치채셨을 거예요. 저희는 이게 정말
중요하다고 생각했어요. 왜냐면 일부 qubit 수는 여전히 고전적으로 시뮬레이션이 가능하기 때문에
그런 칩을 쓸 실질적인 이점이 없거든요. 하지만 100 qubit에서는 더 이상 그렇지 않아요. 고전적으로
시뮬레이션이 불가능해요. 또 한 가지 중요한 점은, 시뮬레이터라는 게 있는데
이건 기본적으로 컴퓨터 프로그램이고, 노이즈를 포함한 양자 시스템의 일부 동작을 흉내낼 수 있어요. 하지만
제가 '흉내낸다'고 했다는 점을 놓치지 마세요. 시뮬레이터는 양자 컴퓨터가 아니에요. 이 규모에서 양자 컴퓨터가 낼 수 있는 결과를
시뮬레이터는 낼 수 없어요. 그래도 테스트 워크플로에서 여전히 중요한 역할을 해요. 이 슬라이드 상단의
질문에 대한 꽤 긴 답이었네요. 실용적인 Quantum Computing이란 무엇인가요? 이 강좌에서 현실적인
양자 활용 사례와 더 큰 규모의 프로세서에서 실험하고 실행하는 모범 사례를 알려드릴 거예요.
그러면 이 강좌는 누구를 위한 걸까요? 레벨 설정부터 시작해 볼게요.
이 강좌는 양자 컴퓨터용 새로운 애플리케이션을 개발하고 싶거나,
현재 작업을 확장하거나 기존 워크플로에 양자를 통합하는 방법을 배우고 싶은 모든 분을 위한 거예요. 앞서
말씀드렸듯이 이 강좌는 실습 위주이고 이론적인 부분은 많이 다루지 않을 거예요.
양자 계산이 무엇인지에 대한 기본적인 이해를 갖고 오시길 바라는데, 아직 거기까지 안 되셨다면 괜찮아요. John Watrous의 강좌
처음 몇 에피소드만 보시면 준비가 될 거예요. 또 시청자분들께서 알아두셨으면 하는 게 있어요.
이 강좌는 물리학자나 컴퓨터 과학자만을 위한 게 아니에요. 이 두 분야가
지난 10여 년간 Quantum Computing을 거의 독점해 왔는데, 빅데이터나
시뮬레이션을 다루는 엔지니어, 화학자, 재료 과학자분들도 이 강좌가 여러분을 위한 것임을 알아주셨으면 해요. 요약하자면
이 강좌는 폭넓은 청중을 대상으로 하고 있고, 전체 과정을 함께해 주시길 바라요. 강좌를 마치면
Qiskit runtime을 통해 유틸리티 규모의 작업을 생성하고 실행하는 방법을 전체 워크플로를 포함해 이해할 수 있게 돼요.
주요 오류 완화 유형을 이해하고 단기적으로 유망한 응용 분야도 파악할 수 있어요. 또한
Qiskit으로 이런 알고리즘들을 모두 실행하고, 마지막으로 노이즈를 이해하고 어떻게 다루는지도 알 수 있게 될 거예요.
자, 시작해 볼게요! Quantum Computing은 개발 초기 단계의 흥미로운 신기술이지만,
수천 년을 거슬러 올라가는 계산의 역사에서 하나의 챕터에 불과해요. 이런
맥락을 이해하는 게 중요하다고 생각해요. 우리가 목표로 하는 것이 좀 더 직관적이고 예측 가능하며 덜
SF처럼 느껴지게 해주거든요. 고대부터 인간은 계산을 수행해야 했어요.
다시 말해, 일정한 규칙과 제약에 따라 정보를 처리해야 했어요.
의사소통, 건설, 상업, 과학, 그리고 삶의 모든 측면을 가능하게 하기 위해서요. 우리는 물리 세계에서
도움을 구했고, 탁월한 발견들을 통해 계산을 돕는 장치들을 만들어냈어요. 오래전 장치들은
나무, 뼈, 매듭 지은 밧줄로 만들어졌고, 지금과는 매우 다른 방식으로 정보를 저장하고 계산을 도왔어요.
레버, 기어, 기타 기계 장치로 만든 기계식 장치들은 초기 천문 시계에서
계산기를 거쳐, 바퀴와 회전 디스크로 방정식을 푸는 미분 분석기 같은 정교한 컴퓨팅 장치로 발전했어요.
문자 기술조차도 이 역사에서 중요한 역할을 했는데, 사람들이 그렇지 않으면
할 수 없었을 계산을 가능하게 해줬기 때문이에요. 오늘날 컴퓨터라고 하면 보통
전자 디지털 컴퓨터를 떠올리지만, 이건 사실 꽤 최근의 기술이에요. 전자 디지털 컴퓨터는
1940년대에 처음 만들어졌어요. 계산을 위한 가장 오래된 도구는 수메르의 주판으로,
전문가들은 기원전 2700~2300년경 바빌론에서 발명됐다고 봐요. 정말
오래전이네요. 하지만 Archimedes부터 Euclid를 거쳐
Einstein에 이르기까지 자연 세계에 대한 이해가 깊어지면서, 더 많은 계산 자원에 대한 수요가 폭발적으로 증가했어요. 오늘날엔 슈퍼컴퓨터가 있는데,
이건 기본적으로 매우 강력한 컴퓨터 여러 대를 병렬로 연결한 거예요. 인류가 가진
어려운 문제를 푸는 최고의 도구 중 하나지만, 이 거대한 컴퓨터들조차 영원히 풀 수 없는 문제들이 여전히 많아요.
이 부분은 나중에 더 다룰게요. 인간이 수천 년 동안 계산을 위해 물리학과 자연을 활용해 왔다는 걸 확인했고,
더 크고 많은 것을 계산하려는 끝없는 탐구를 계속해 왔다는 것도요. 이미 짐작하실 수도 있겠지만,